Here We Go From The Daily Mail former
proud boys leader Joe Biggs sobs during
sentencing as he's given 17 years in
prison over January 6 after begging
Court not to separate him from his
daughter and cancer-stricken mom Biggs
Ethan Nordeen Zachary Rail and mkhitarya
were all found guilty of the charges
after they broke into the capital
following 2020 election full stop fake
news Enrique tario is actually not there
so uh yeah his charges I don't believe
anything to do with him he was arrested
beforehand and barred from the city
tario was not there so uh you gotta you
gotta correct that one Daily Mail
the judge ruled Biggs was qualified for
a terrorism sentencing enhancement big
sentence is one of the harshest handed
out in capital Riot cases only behind
the 18-year sentence for Oath Keepers
founder Stuart Rhodes
here's where it gets interesting so this
is Joe Biggs many of you may know him he
worked for uh Infowars he said I know
that I have to be punished I understand
but he added please give me the chance I
beg you to take my daughter to school
and pick her up I wanted to see what
would happen my curiosity got the best
of me I am not a terrorist I'm one of
the nicest people in the world judge
Timothy Kelly wasn't having it as he
said Americans are the Envy of the world
and U.S elections must be respected
telling Biggs you did play a role in
riling up the crowd if you don't like
how an election is being conducted you
can speak out call write or meet with
election officials you can engage in
peaceful protest file a lawsuit that
right there is why I think we absolutely
have to talk about this story because
that judge lied or he's really dumb
maybe both uh if you peacefully protest
like the people who were walking around
the other side of the building
they're going to arrest you anyway if
you say sit in front of an abortion
clinic they're going to try to give you
11 years in prison because you
peacefully protested how about this if
you speak out on Twitter they'll claim
it's part of a criminal conspiracy if
you make a phone call part of a criminal
conspiracy write or meet with election
officials not only are they charging
Donald Trump his staff and legal team
for doing these things they've even
criminally charged the election
officials that they met with
so this is insanity 17 years why what
did he do he tore a fence down should he
have done it no should he have been
punished or prosecuted or whatever yeah
two and a half years maybe a little
harsh for tearing down a fence you take
a look at what what happened with the
far left extremists BLM or otherwise
nothing
so this is particularly extreme we have
some commentary here
Matt Walsh says a man just got 17 years
in prison for tearing down a fence on
January 6. meanwhile a guy responsible
for burning an entire police station to
the ground during the BLM riots got only
four years no sane person thinks this is
justice but we do not live in a sane
world it is an insane world and of
course Marjorie Taylor green has come
out saying proud boys organizer Joseph
big sentence to 17 years by U.S District
Judge Timothy Kelly how many violent BLM
writers are serving 17 years especially
after rotting in jail for the past two
years j6ers need to be pardoned they've
been persecuted enough
I have um
you know this this is the kind of thing
that gives me a sinking feeling because
what I what I did following the story is
I went to look at a few forums to see
what the sentiment was among Trump
supporters and uh fans of Joe Biggs and
uh
yo it's getting scary out there because
the response from these people is
terrifyingly as I've predicted the view
the government is illegitimate law
enforcement doesn't exist and the
perception among those who support
Donald Trump is increasingly becoming
and from any already is that these law
enforcement officers are no different
than a guy in a clown costume that if a
person walks up to you wearing a set of
clothes it doesn't mean anything they're
now saying that this is soviet-style
Communist Revolution this is what was
happening to the Spanish Civil War and
if this escalates and likely will
because the far left will not stop
they're going insane they they're I
don't know if they're a zombie horde
setting fired everything around them
just screeching the top of their lungs
or it's intentional but
you want to know who's at fault for the
continuous drive in this country it's
not Joe Biggs it's it's it's this judge
17 years that's going to freak people
out and not the way they think now
here's here's what I want to add before
we just jump into the full conversation
the reason why they gave him 17 years it
has nothing to do with who Joe Biggs is
or what he did it's because of the mob
phenomenon and they want everyone to
know that they will throw the book at
you and the hammer if you engage in any
kind of mob mentality phenomenon that is
to say
often what we see in these riots with
far left you have a mob of people
walking around clueless one guy will
walk up to a door at a store and jiggle
the handle and then run away another guy
will run up within a split second as
he's running away and grab the handle
and pull the door open
someone else will see the door being
opened and they'll peek their head in
someone behind him will shove him in
then people see people going in the
building and they all start rushing the
building there was no immediate action
where an individual thought to
themselves we should storm this building
and that's what happens with Joe Biggs
he's just there he has no idea what's
going on despite the fact they say that
there's Communications by the proud boys
yeah they were saying like what are we
doing what's going on he's there people
start taking action and he goes along
with it so they're basically setting an
example we don't care who you are we
don't care what you've done if you are
in the mob you're going down and that's
why the people who did not get violent
and had no idea was happening in the
side of the building are being
criminally charged the courts have
literally told them because you were
part of a mob you are going to prison I
with Joe Biggs uh one of those tweets is
the first tweet you pulled up said that
he's getting so Matt Walsh 17 years for
tearing down a fence but Kellen you
mentioned before the show he was also
screaming a bear kid he was also yelling
to people to go in and to do stuff no no
I just said they were proud like there's
there's videos of him saying we just we
just did it yeah we were just in there
like heck yeah they were half
and the video in the court and the trial
was someone walking out to him being
like we just got in the capital what do
you think and he goes awesome okay so
he's just celebrating I mean there's
also video of Zachary reel who's also
sentenced today he's getting 15 years
and he was also convicted of suspicious
conspiracy during this three-month trial
uh of him saying don't go into the
capitol don't go in there and they're
like irrelevant to us you have to go in
because later you threw something at a
police officer I mean there are things
where I can agree like it was don't
throw stuff at cops don't throw
something out of hand on the other hand
both of these men have young children
and you're locking them up to prove your
political Point yeah and that's pretty
sick it's it's I the metaphor I think is
like if a bully attacks another kid in
school everyone's like oh God you want
the bully to lose so the kid somehow
fights back and he beats the bully and
he knocks the bully down then everyone's
like Yay but if the kid starts stomping
on the bully's face and smashing his
skull people will run over and grab the
kid and pull him off this government has
gone too far by hitting these guys with
17 years they're now smashing the skull
of the guy that there it's unnecessary a
bit brutal but I agree extremely brutal
what they're doing and it's gonna cause
massive anti system couldn't cause
sentiment that people are gonna start to
hate the victim now this is right this
is even even the krakensteins are like
we think this is a little bit harsh yeah
and I'm like wow well and Kelly is the
second judge that has said something to
the effect of like because of you we no
longer have stable elections and because
it's this judge's fault I I hope
everybody make like you understand that
you know to to throw a point to Ian who
often talks about pardoning your enemies
now I don't completely agree with
pardoning the worst war criminals of Our
Generation but there is something to be
said of the Chinese finger trap problem
in that the harder you pull the worse
you make it and this is the judge being
the judge may as well have looked into
the camera for the for NBC News and CNN
and said that his goal is to destroy
this country because the sentiment among
those who support Trump is that they are
coming for you they are coming for your
families they are they're using violence
they are like the the sentiment is not
well Justice was served
it's it's done the exact opposite this
is radicalizing people because the
sentence is psychotic right I was
thinking uh the the sentencing disparity
that Matt Walsh brought up could that be
the difference between prosecution and a
federal uh with a federal judge versus
like the really relaxed uh persecution
or prosecution that's happening for
different states in the different cities
perhaps but that but to the moral
question it doesn't really matter all
that much right right obviously we know
that the feds can be more harsh they
tend to win all of their cases the ones
they choose but it's just when you look
at these on the surface of what they are
obviously we can say bro if you're gonna
get in into a fight with FEDS You're
Gonna Lose hands down but 17 years for
knocking down a a barrier I mean it was
one of those like little metal barriers
yeah so it's not good you shouldn't do
it and I think you'd go to jail for it
but you'd think someone would get like
six seven months in jail for something
like that and I feel like I have to
maybe not even there two months I have
to point out that the justice department
asked for 33 years and they asked for 27
for Zachary Wheels I mean this is
basically sort of half of what they
wanted and it's still in my opinion way
too much for what happened right and the
one thing I want to bring up is the uh
you remember the the case where the New
York City lawyers
during the 2020 protests they were
caught with the molotov cocktails they
got pretty good sentencing from it so
they weren't given lenient sensing not
saying that this isn't harsh but I think
it's been
I think the feds are making an example
quite clearly
um and it's it's unjustified
um and like you said it's radicalizing
people as well so they're not they're
making an example while at the same time
radicalizing people which could possibly
create the same circumstance that we
ended up before and and I don't think
they're they care much about that like
they're thinking that step ahead but I
think for us who are just analyzing
things that seems like a plausible thing
that could happen
um and God forbid like one of these
indictments go through with with Trump
that uh to be honest I'm not a lawyer
but just looking at the different
indictments they don't make much sense
to me I I think that uh biggest lawyer
should file an appeal on the grounds
that the judge advocated for criminal
activity that the judge attempted to
incite the uh the defendant and his
associates and those listening to commit
crimes and incitement to commit a crime
is a crime in and of itself so I believe
this judge should be impeached he should
be removed and criminally charged for
the crime of advocating and inciting
others to engage in an elected election
interference and Sedition conspiracy
because he outright said if you don't
like how the election's been conducted
speak out call right army with election
officials as we know based on what
happened in Georgia and the federal
charges that's illegal so I I think
we're going to have to ask the
Republicans to criminally charge this
judge uh this Trump appointee judge I'm
going to throw that I don't care who
appointed him I think that's what when I
went to cover opening statements that
was what was interesting about sitting
with the families was they were saying
like Kelly is a trump appointee he's
been some like he's been more flexible
about some things because a lot of them
go into this DC courthouse being like I
am in a hostile city where the jury is
already biased against our case and I
have a democrat-appointed judge they
feel doomed from the beginning and this
only uh affirms This Feeling from people
who support these people saying you know
the government is out to get us no
matter what I mean 300 people are in
jail because of January 6 over a
thousand have been charged federally it
just seems like I I can't imagine being
a business owner in a city where there
were significant writing rioting during
the summer of 2020 and thinking like wow
I wish someone cared about what happened
to me as much as DC cares about what
happens to itself I mean they
experienced so much there was so much
loss there and yet all of the focuses on
these people and one specific day it
seems it seems disproportionate to me
this is not
it is it is an incredible naivety to
think that a 17-year sentence will set
an example for anybody the only example
this judge has set is that there is a
biased neolib neocon uniparty machine
that will destroy your life unjustly if
you speak out against them in any way
and of course that's not me defending
what Joe Biggs did and tearing down a
barricade and you know going into the
capital or whatever he should not have
done that I imagine Riot charge would be
a couple of months or something maybe
followed by probation or whatever
but when you look at the crimes
committed by the far left it is fairly
obvious they're they're being paid money
when the far leftists rioted in DC and
burned and set fire to buildings and
garbage in the street and the limousine
smashing Windows the city paid them
millions of dollars paid them after they
got arrested when it's the right at the
Capitol I mean look and you've also had
the left Storm Into the Senate and you
know buildings and and bang on the
Supreme Court doors and going to the
Capitol all of that not a peep nobody
cares so all that they're doing is
setting an example that you have
oppressors willing to use Force against
you to take you from your children and
like if you look at the forums what
people are saying I've I've the
radicalization is terrifying and Joe
Biden can do this and then he's gonna
say we're not tough on crime or we are
tough on crime we talk about San
Francisco and New York we locked all
these guys up from j6 what they're gonna
say we protect democracy right they're
gonna that's what we do we're battling
domestic terrorism never mind what
happens to the cities outside eye of DC
never mind the people who lost their
businesses in in 2020 we don't care
about what happens to them we care about
what happens to us as the head of the
government this has got to be like uh
they're anticipating riots if they take
Trump off the ballot and they want to
intimidate people into not riding or be
like hey make an example of Joe Biggs
don't even think about it 17 years if
you even think about it kind of thing
but like you got to understand the
damage it's not people aren't machines
they don't they don't respond A to B
like a like a computer program and if
you
just you just can't test twist this man
there's a reason that we have this this
system built like it's built so that
people in the center don't take control
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time